[Music]
we paid a heavy price
but the trap worked you seem surprised
it's been a while since we've had a win
how long will it hold i've never
entrapped a being like this
but the bonds hold
for now how do we dispose of it
i'm just a witch you're the soldier
if it bleeds i can kill it
how do you kill a spirit though
if you kill the mortal vessel while it's
bound the spirit may perish within
if it escapes it's listening to us
what are you
others of your time nameless
why have you invaded our world your
world
i've heard enough of this rubbish
let's hang it
[Music]
destroy this lesson and i will find
another i have tasted its desires
emotions your kind is weak
you have already watched this move
do it
captain cut him down
what are you mad better safe than sorry
the spirit has fled this is a human now
the captain is correct
when they awaken
they won't remember a thing
[Music]
the ethereal was right the war is lost
we're a resistance now and we need every
human survivor we can call to our cause
maybe this one here can still die with
some honor
if they ever wake up
send them to me
if they don't
bury him deep with the others
[Music]
[Music]
still drawing breath i see
you're one lucky bastard i'll give you
that
best go speak to captain bourbon right
away he seems to have a plan for you now
that we've spared your life
you were possessed
so we uh strung you up
seems the spirit fled your body before
your life ran out
i'd have left you to hang but uh the
captain had other plans he sees some
purpose in you and i'm not going to
argue
he's um up the road
in the courtyard
don't make me regret cutting you down
[Music]
[Applause]
so you're the one we almost hung
i didn't really see a sense in it but
then again no one really cares what old
barnabas thinks
you really should go speak with the
captain
he'll be the one deciding whether
there's a place for you here at devil's
crossing
you're not looking too bad for someone
just come back from the brink of death
you were taken possessed by the same
creatures that have been reanimating
these zombies here
normally i'd have burned you with the
rest to be safe but we've lost too many
people to the dead
i need someone expendable someone with
nothing to lose but a lot to gain right
now
you are that person
prove your worth to me and the survivors
of devil's crossing may just welcome you
the bodies of the dead are rising again
in some horrible unlife
corpses don't just get up and move
around on their own
something is reanimating our deceased
with ethereal energy
we have observed the dead for some time
and they appear to be flooding lower
crossing from the burial hill just
beyond town
i want you to go to the burial hill find
whatever is controlling his abominations
and destroy it
you will need to fight your way through
lower crossing once you've crossed the
stream on the far side of town there
will be a beaten path leading up to
burial hill
i know i'm asking a lot of you but i'd
be asking a lot of my people to welcome
you with open arms too
help us in our hour of need and i will
open devil's crossing to you
[Music]
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
hmm
um
so
what
um
[Music]
uh
what
good
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
six
six
[Music]
so
[Music]
shhh
what
so
good
[Music]
uh
what
[Music]
the dead attacks have slowed and their
numbers are thinning i take that as a
sign that you've dealt with a source
a creature was doing this
disturbing
thanks to your efforts we may yet hold
out here a little longer i've sent word
to the gate guard speak to him and he
should let you in
take some well-deserved time to rest and
recover
welcome to devil's crossing
i need some time